mrs. Li Tyson she was a physical
manifestation of a dream that had not
materialized in the life of a
dark-skinned pinky head little girl in
Central Falls Rhode Island and when I
saw her in autobiography of Miss Jane
Pittman and I saw that excellence of
craft she made me believe that I could
do it I saw myself in her it's like she
just reached up and that TV took my hand
and said I'm gonna take you down this
path
she was everything she is everything to
me the biggest lesson that she taught me
is that you got to see it I think that
what's happening sometimes a lot of
young people with a lot of people in
general is they don't believe they're
worthy and then you have to understand
you don't hustle for your work you don't
barter for your worth
you are born worthy mr. Sidney Porter
seeing him kind of carry the torch and
several others but it was something
about mr. Poirier that was special and
always inspired me to want to be great
and understand that you have to step
into it and he just did in so many ways
he was first in so many ways he got the
opportunity and he sees